それで繰り返して繰り返して同じ禅定に入ると
簡単に第一禅定に入れるようになります
で それ第一禅定の特色はこの前説明しましたね
この あの 知識は働いています
概念 言葉とかね は働いています
これヴィタック・ヴィチャーラというんですが
それでピーティ すごい喜びがあります
ものすごい喜びがあります
スッカ 喜悦感があります
すごいこの体の この体で本当に感じるんです
ものすごい喜悦感というか楽しみというかって感じなんです
それからもう徹底的に落ち着いている
そこで難しいのは この落ち着いてるって
あの 一境性というこのサマーディ状態なんですね
同じ状態でじーっといられるっていうことはあるんだけど
そこでちょっとしたことで
この一境性ということには切れちゃうんですね
それでまた元に戻っちゃうんです
ですから この禅定を守りたい人は
この あの できるだけこの落ち着いていることを守ってほしい
何が起ころうと何のことなく
こんな心で対象を見ている
例えば瞑想していると
壁を見て瞑想していると
皆様にはどれぐらい時間
経験 あの 実践 実験したことがどなたかあります？ない
この前言ったんだけど
はい やりました やりました
どういうふうな経験がありますか？ まだない
一応  あの ずっと見てると目が痛くなってきちゃうんです
で だからしばらく目が痛くなってきたら
あの 閉じます  ですから
やっぱりじーっと じーっと見るんじゃないんです
だからやってみたら その
見るとはなしに見るような見方をしてみたいに
じっと見てたいと 見るとはなしの見方をしてても
結局じっと見ちゃってる時間があるみたいなんですが
なるほど  で 目閉じて また痛くなったったらまた開けて
みたいに  そういう  ちょっと力入りすぎなんですね
で そうで それでもいろんな変なもの見えるんじゃないですか
色が変わってくる  えっ？ 色が変わってくるような
うん  問題なら  うん そういう
色が変わったり またいろいろ形が見えたりとかね
また白い色を見ているのに
違うもの全く見えたりとかいろいろありますよ
そういうふうに自分の目が
この見てる対象の実際にある他のものに自然的に行っちゃうんです
だからあまり力入れて見ると
自分が強引に見ているんだから自由がないんですね
視覚に だから視覚に自由を与えてください
もうなんかぼーっと見てるだけ
として見てる方が楽ですね
そうそうそう  そういうふうな状態で
うん そうそうそう  もしそれでも目が疲れてきたら見たら
やっぱ閉じて  うん  ずっと見てると
そこら辺ももうすごくリラックスしてね
まばたきはしていいですか？ それは別にまあ
だから距離もね 自分の視力によって正しい距離があるんですね
ですから 私はちょっとその距離はちょっと皆様いろいろ近眼とかいっぱい日本にありますから
僕らとちょっと距離が言えないですね
まあ僕らの国だったら近眼の人一人もいませんだからね
目は見えるんですけど
ですから この自分の目には何のことなく見えるぐらいの距離にしておかなくちゃいけない
近眼だとやっぱり眼鏡かけた方がいいかもしれませんね
こうやって見るよりは
だからそれも一つのハンディなんですよ
しょうがないんだけどね
だから日本では子供の時は目がいいでしょ？みんな
子供の時やらせた方がいいですね
子供とかみんなすごい目がいいんです
大人になってくると ね
体大きくなってくると
こっちちょっと目がおかしくなってきて
眼鏡かけなくちゃいけないんですね
まあそれとにかく この
あの あまり力入れすぎちゃいけないんですね
あまりこの禅定とかそんなものなくたっても
ちょっと十分ぐらい見たところでも
なんかいろいろもの見えてくるんですね
見えてくると なんとなく心の中がちょっと混乱しちゃうんです
あれ 面白くなっちゃうとか
なんだこれとかね あの辺の混乱なしの平気で冷静に見続けるという能力が必要なんですね
あれ？と思わない  そうそうそう
ただ 本当はそう思ってしまっちゃうんで
それすごい難しいんです
ちょっと変に見えちゃったら
あれ？ってなっちゃうんです
あれっつって一瞬でも思っても
もうそのまま流すしかない
それはもう試行錯誤というんですかね
まあ何回 何回繰り返してやっちゃえばいいんだけどね
あれと思った瞬間に消えちゃうんですね
だから一境性というんですね
集中力ですね 集中力を保たなくちゃいけない
だから 例えば瞑想進んで禅定に入っても禅定が切れるのはこの集中力を失っている時なんですね
冷静でいられないと すごくすごく難しいんです
心が一つのものだけ見ているということは
消えても構いません それは自然的だからね
仏教ではあまり気にしませんだけどね
禅定状態で長い時間いられないんです
悟った人だけ煩悩が消えちゃったんだから
1週間ぐらいは居られるんだそうです
同じ状態 それもすべての煩悩消えた人だけ
他の誰にもできない やっぱり驚いちゃうね
だから今日言いたかったのは
そういうちょっとした実験を試してみると
今まで見ているものが何か違う形で見えてくる
それ 今おっしゃったように
色が変わってくるや またいろいろ形が見えてくるわ
穴は見えるわとかね 凸凹が見えるわとか
そこで人があれ 私の視力が良くなったんじゃないですかとか
いろいろ思ったりするかもしれません
壁を見てます 凸凹見えてくる
それはもう虫眼鏡で見ない限りは見えないものなんですね
ただ見ただけで凸凹見えてくると僕にも見えるんですよ
ちょっと見ただけで もう 1分もかからないうちに
もう全部凸凹やらもうあーだこうだとか
そこでなるほど 今は老眼で困ってるのに
もうなんて虫眼鏡のように見えるだろうと思っちゃったら
そこでもう見えなくなっちゃうんですね
ですから いつでも冷静とクールな心で見続ける能力が必要ということなんです
ですから とにかく第一禅定に入ったら
その気絶感があって 心がすごく楽に
体がすごく楽になって
その上一境性という集中力がある
第2番目の禅定 また同じく第2番目の禅定の場合は
この知識働かないてもなくてもいい
言葉なくても済む  第2と3アビダンマでは
第2と3 お経では第2
だから禅定はどこら辺？分かれ方分け方がどっちが正しいかとか
私分かりませんだけど
お経の分野では分け方は分かりやすいんです
第1禅定では知識は働いています
考え方  第2禅定は考え方は働いてない
考えてない ただいるだけ
いる それですごい気絶感感じる
集中力がある それが第2番目の禅定
その第2番 阿比達磨で二つに割ってるんです
それだけ それで第三番目の禅定になってくると
このピーティという この
ああ 悲しい気持ちという状態は消えるんですね
阿比達磨のサンなんですけど
ちょっと待って じゃあアビダルマ的に説明します
ちゃんと 第二禅定ではヴィタッカという
この 強引に言葉を使うことは消える
第三禅定ではヴィチャーラが消える
ヴィチャーラっていうのは言葉使わなくても概念的に行くということなんですね
だい これサンですね それからピーティ次書いた
第四番目 四番目になると言葉も何もない
ただ楽だけあって そうすると五番目入っちゃいます
五番目ウペッカーでしょ
うん これパーリ語で使わなきゃ
一番目はヴィタッカ・ヴィチャーラ・ピーティ・スケーガター・サイタン・パタマッジャーナー
二番目はヴィチャーラ・ピーティ・スケーガター・サイタン・デュティアッジャーナー
三番目はピーティ・スケーガター・サイタン
いわゆる三番目ではピーティ
すごく楽しくて言葉ない状態でいられる
四番目はスカーイ・エガター・サイタン
四番目の禅定に入る 四番目じゃなくて
四番目ですね すごく喜悦感がある
これは物質的な楽しいということじゃなくて
それは体の感覚もあんまり消えちゃったような状態で
なんかすごい喜悦感があって
落ち着いて また集中力がある
四番目 五番目の禅定ではこの喜悦感も消えちゃうんです
シャー ただ集中力があって
自分がいるだけ それだけの
なんかいるという感覚
感じだけ それ以上は色界の心は進めないんです
五つに分けてますが お経では四つなんです
四つの段階 もしかするとその間
いろんな禅定のレベルあるかもしれません
第一と二の間 二と三の間
三と四の間 四と五の間とかね
いろんな宗教でいろんなやり方で瞑想してますけどね
こちらの禅定っていうのはすっごいものすごい大きなステップなんですね
だからどんな宗教の瞑想でも何か神秘的な体験があるというならば
その体験が本物であるならば
このシステムで解釈できるんです
本物でないともうただのゴミだから別に気にする必要ないんだけどね
神秘体験っていうのはあり得ることだからね
ですから 大体この第一禅定も簡単に得られるもんでしょうね
ですから これはよくヨガの瞑想している人々も
結構ヨガ完成しましたという人々がいて
話聞くとサッチット・アーナンダンですか
もう大変喜びを感じたんだと
一体感があるからやっぱり梵我一如の体験したと違っちゃいますけど
話聞けばまあただ第一禅定ぐらいには入ってるんですね
ですから なぜならばその時言葉消えたかというと
それでもないし で まあ喜び感じている
本当に体で喜びを感じているし
まあそれだけ それで消える
その経験が ずっとあるわけじゃない
じゃあ二番 二度とやってみてくださいったら
また難しいんです じゃあ二度とまた同じ梵我一如の経験に入ってみてくださいというと
その人々にできない 一回やったらもうやったぞという風に言っちゃう
それが良くないって仏教で言ってるんですね
一回経験したら繰り返し繰り返し繰り返しやらなくちゃいけないんです
やってそれに慣れるんです
驚かないようにするために
慣れたら二番目 三番目
四番目 五番目の禅定まで行けるんです
五番目に行ったらこの喜悦感がないんです
そうするとサッチット・アーナンダンという哲学は消えてるはずなんです
だからヒンドゥー教の中国の哲学というのはサッチット・アーナンダンという
これ日本語でどうなります？サッチット・アーナンダン
真理と 日本訳は ヨガでよく使う言葉でしょ
聞いたことない？ そういうのはあまり使わないです
正しく教えてもらわないので
まあそれ宗派によって変わりますからね
本願寺派みたいな サッ
チッ アーナンダ サッっていうのは真理
チッっていうのは魂 心
アーナンダっていうのは至福
いわゆるとにかくヒンドゥー教ではもう一般的な言葉なんですね
真理と自分のコガと至福っていうのが神学
それが一体感を出して
だから一体感が出てくると
そこで至福感も生まれるっていうことで
その哲学を作ってるんですね
それはもうものすごく仏教からね
仏教の精一杯の深説に解釈すると
第一 二 三番目までの禅定なんですね
四番目まで アビダンマで言えば
で アーナンダンという至福感という言葉も消えちゃったら五番目の禅定なんですね
でも 遠い昔 インドでは五番目まで行った人々はいたんです
その禅定の教えは仏教の教えじゃないんです
インドであった瞑想法なんです
お釈迦様はそれは仏教で心理学的に解釈していて
お釈迦様も実践してあって
お坊さんたちも普通に誰でも実践するもの
いわゆるヨーガ瞑想っていうのはヒンドゥー教の後で入ったことで
それは僕一般的なインドで誰でもやる瞑想なんですね
ヒンドゥー教はそれを受け入れたところで
我々のものやと なんかヨーロッパ人と同じく人の国を取っちゃって自分のものにしちゃった
そんなもんなんですね
もともと誰でもやってたものでね
ですから 誰やったっても同じこと
で 五番目の禅定に入ったら至福感もない
なんとなく冷静なこと
喜びも感じない 苦しみも感じない
単なるいるのみという状態
それぐらい心成長すると
いろんなことを自由自在にすることできるんです
物質を自由自在にコントロールすることできます
もう三次元をもう飛んでいってるんだから
そこで何次元の物質はその心が自由通りにすることができます
いわゆる神通力ですか
そこができるのは もうアビダンマでは五番目の禅定
お経では四番目の禅定に入ってからなんです
能力としてはつく場合はあります
おまけに でも本物の神通力っていうのはおまけに付くんじゃなくて
これを訓練して身に付いてもらうんです
おまけに付くものはその分はね
いろいろ問題ありますけどね
自分がちゃんと免許証を取ったならば自由自在に使えるんです
そこでこの 例えば壁を通っていきたいんだと思ったら
第五番目で禅定ある人にとっては
またさらに瞑想して この瞑想の能力でその意思ですか
心のエネルギーを絞って希望するんです
壁に自分に通れるような
この壁 この物体通れるような穴あってほしい
そしたら壁に穴ができちゃうんです
その人にだけ通れるんです
他の人には穴は見えないと
地面に沈めたければ そこら辺自分が沈めるような状態を作ると
そうするとそれの中にじっと中に入ることできるんです
自然に ですから そこは今なんとなく本当かなという疑いで心が出てくるでしょ
それは三次元はリアルだと思ってるんだからなんです
物質の世界は 瞑想ではそのリアルがないんです
リアルだと思わないんです
心の命令によって体がすぐ変化するんですからね
今もそういう経験があると思いますけど
例えば眠たくて眠たくている瞬間で
ちょっとチラッと音が耳に入っちゃったらすぐ目が覚めちゃうでしょうね
瞬時に物質が変わりますからね
心によって 今もあることなんです
人造的なレベルというのはね
ただ成長していない 五時
四時半と言われました
もういいかと思いますけど
まあ一応まあ今日で色界の心は終わるということにします
十五種類あります 二番目のセットは
この依宿心なんです ということは
この瞑想した人が 禅定ある人にとっては生まれ変わると人間に戻らない
三次元には戻らない 生まれ変わる場合
もう心は次元超えちゃったんだから梵天に生まれるんです
だからヒンズー教でも言っているように
もう当然ながら当たり前に梵天には行くんです
ですから 梵天に生まれる場合は
この禅定のレベルによって
もうどこかに生まれますよ
そこで生まれると それは依宿心という
そこにある心は色界の依宿心なんです
瞑想しなくたっても禅定の心なんです
でもここで行ったここのことの結果だから依宿心と言われます
そこで阿羅漢になった人がヴィパッサナー瞑想して阿羅漢になったと
でも阿羅漢になったって普通の知識で生きてるんだから
まあ苦しいし もういろいろ体の病気があったり
いろいろあるでしょ 禅定ぐらいに入っちゃったら楽しいじゃないかと思って
もう禅定を作ると 煩悩は全くないんだからカルマにならない
禅定には入られます ですから
阿羅漢になった方々は有為色身
瞑想してると 生まれ変わりはない
ただの行為で終わっちゃう
そういう風に十五種類の色界の心があります
ということで色界は終わりますと
ありがとうございます
ありがとうございました